Christopher Paul Anthony at the Stefano. Could you get it more Italian,
do you think? Or no. No. Uh, well, Paul,
my dad wanted to change my middle name from Paul because he found out that, um,
in 1984,
the number one name amongst gay men who are coming out of the closet was Paul in
the year I was born and my mother, like you you're setting them up for gay life
growing up. It was, um, yeah, it was like pre gentrification.
So it was kind of like where all like people now,
like in Ridgewood Bushwick area where I'm from, like,
I remember it was like a very famous pizzeria there now called Roberta's it's
famous to like the hipsters and um, in like 1997,
like that's where me and my friends, our first dead body, like we saw dead body,
like chalk old school chocked out, like dead drug overdose, like absolute,
like the neighborhood Bushwick was on fire for the nineties. Like,
it didn't matter if you were black, Spanish, white, Chinese, your parents,
you would never go past flushing Avenue.
And that's now where like all the gluten-free Arteezy and my mom still owns the
same house. I grew up in my whole life and it's like a dilapidated,
like not a nice house at all. It's like barely livable,
but she can get like millions of dollars for it because these hipsters just want
to live by the train. And we're like, yeah, face.
If you want to pay $10,000 for this one room rat hole, do it.
We'll take your money. Like a Hasidic Jewish guy.
The other day came and offered her like 1.5 million in cash. And she was like,
you don't know where they get their money from. I was like,
that's how I first got on shows. When I first started comedy,
like doing open mics, like handing out flyers for comedy clubs or bringer shows.
But a lot of times like comedians who have went on to do great things. Now,
when they were at a lower level, they would be like, Hey,
I heard you like a physical therapist, which to them,
they think that's like a doctor, nobody has health insurance. They were like,
can you look at my Dick? Like,
I've looked down the urethra's of so many comedians who have done so many great
things now it's true. Cause they're so nervous about STDs.
And I would tell them like, Hey, I'm not legally licensed to look at a penis.
Like I can give you back massages or leg massage. But like, they're like, yeah,
but you got a doctorate degree. It's like, good enough. Like I just,
you gotta tell me and I'd be like, listen, I'm not qualified to tell you,
but it is herpes. I would almost say guarantee,
but really gay all boys Catholic schools get really, really gay.
As a matter of fact, my junior year of my high school,
I went to artificial malign high school.
They announced that they were going to let girls in the next year and we staged
a walkout. We were like, you will not let it here. We walked out. We stayed.
It's like a protest in the year, 2000. And be like, if you let women in here,
we're not coming in. That's how gay it got. Uh, no, the women came and we were.
You know, we were like, this, this is our thing, you know, like we're skies.
And so, but it got it got gay. And then, and then, and then, yeah, I mean,
but like, I think every Catholic like has that story where they're like,
you know, you know, with a priest, like in the back of the church,
he tells you to go up and get a certain kind of robe, blackout, um,
sex in public. Uh [inaudible] no,
no, I never, I never had sex. I've never had sex in public. I,
the craziest place I had sex is at a funeral and the bed in the back. Yeah.
Like in a bathroom, but yeah, we had texted, I had sex in a funeral.
A friend's father had died. So like, I it's,
we had been friends like all from the same neighborhood and you know,
she was just like, I'm so horny. I was like.
Winky dank. Me too. Yeah.